l'issue du vote ne faisait pas de doute
les conservateurs détenant la majorité à
la chambre des communes
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir c'est donc
chose faite
les députés ont voté ce soir on vient le
voir par 142 votes pour 129 contre le
prolongement d'un an de la participation
canadienne à la coalition militaire
contre le groupe est un islamique
les frappes aériennes s'étendront
dorénavant à la syrie emmanuel
maintenant que le vote est passé ça
devrait se faire assez vite s
conséquente est ce que ces frappes
peuvent commencer
céline ce serait une question de jours
en croire des sources au sein du
gouvernement les cf-18 sont prêts nous
dit-on il s'agit maintenant d'identifier
les cibles
tout ça bien sûr sous commandement
américain des frappes canadienne et sur
son très controversé alors que le canada
va s'aventurer au coeur du conflit qui
déchire la syrie tout ça alors que vous
avez hier le président bachar al assad
en entrevue avec 6 10 minutes affirmé
que selon lui les frappes aériennes
n'ont pas donné les effets escomptés en
séries jusqu'ici lui croit plutôt que le
groupe armé était cela me prend de
l'expansion et recrutent davantage de
militants au sein de son groupe
le gouvernement lui répond qu'il en va
de la sécurité nationale et que le
canada doit pour chasser ce groupe armé
islamique là où ils se trouvent
le premier ministre par ailleurs vous
allez voir qui admet qu'il est bien
difficile de dire quand est ce que la
coalition viendra à bout du groupe armé
là dessus je vous laisse écouter et le
d'essentiel en irak et aussi en cire et
de dinde affaiblir la capacité des sols
de faire cette attaque
or dans la région est-ce que je peux
promettre
l'atteinte de cet objectif en douze ans
c'est pas certain
le premier ministre m vous aurez compris
qu'il voulait plutôt dire 12 mois au
lieu de 12 heures oui alors l'opposition
a voté contre or on sait que les
canadiens sont plutôt en faveur de cette
mission est-ce que sa place pas emmanuel
l'opposition dans une position assez
délicate mais lundi - je voudrais parce
qu'il défend une position qui lui y est
traditionnel un monsieur mulcair qui
soutient que cette guerre-là n'est tout
simplement pas la guerre du canada
la difficulté pour le parti libéral
c'est de plaider que oui le canada a un
jour on l'a joué au sein de la coalition
mais pas le rôle que le gouvernement
veut lui donner une chose sur laquelle
les deux parties s'entendent eux
reprochent au gouvernement de proposer
une canne aux canadiens une option sans
objectifs clairs sans stratégie de
sortie et surtout d'avoir induit les
canadiens en erreur sur le rôle de
combat des forces spéciales je vous
laisse écouter les deux chefs
comment pouvons-nous avoir confiance en
leur gouvernement qui trop si
délibérément la population canadienne
d'abord sur la nature de notre rôle est
maintenant sur la durée de notre
engagement
ils ont tout simplement pas de plan ils
n'ont pas de stratégie autres les
considérations politiques domestiques
puis on l'entend dans toutes leurs
interventions ils trahissent nos pensées
profondes à dieu et ça monsieur le
président sam est non seulement la
crédibilité du canada en danger c'est
même la sécurité de nos troupes en
danger
fait intéressant céline avant même que
le vote ait eu lieu
l'opposition avait déjà choisi un autre
enjeu sur lequel martelé le gouvernement
s'est bien sûr l'enjeu de l'opposé de
l'économie nous démocrates et libéraux
qui sont convaincus que c'est sur cet
enjeu là que va se jouer la prochaine
campagne électorale et non pas sur la
sécurité en économie quand est ce qu'il
sera déposé ce fameux budget sur les
voeux promet de mettre fin au mystère
très bientôt mais déjà on aura compris
que ça va venir après la pause de parc
oui donc en avril merci la meilleure
voie